biggest ceo earners today
uh in america top three are microsoft
ceo satya nadella 42.9 million dollar
salary
uh number three number two is uh uh wait
a minute so let me see
top three okay that's the one microsoft
number two is robert swan of intel 66.1
mil
66.9 million dollars at number two and a
big shock number one
the ceo of google parent company
alphabet sundar
pichai whose compensation is a fiscal
2019 total of 280
million six hundred thousand dollars
that's a salary
facebook seo mark zuckerberg 23.9 23.4
million dollars made only 94 times more
than his employees
but that's the lowest of all ceos listed
most on the list earn
several hundred times more than their
workers
so so when you hear these numbers what
do you think about it well i think you
got to just
you know draw a line in the sand and say
all right man if we are capitalist and
we believe
in in that type of you know business and
and economy then we got to root for them
that means they did something right that
means they had a great year
you know it it's it's touchy i think i
look at it simply this
it's a scoreboard it's a fun little
thing to look at at the end of the year
it's so far off in the stratosphere for
most people there's nothing you can do
about it
it's just mind-boggling to think of some
of these numbers and and how about the
guy you got to give
sunday uh however you pronounce his name
the head of alphabet credit for staying
under the radar screen
the guy's never in the news you never
hear about them very
very very in the background and that's a
that's a hefty compensation but you also
have to read between the lines a little
bit and that's not their salary i mean
they're cashing in stock
and its bonuses and its incentives so
you know more power to them
yeah i think when you break it down i
think the media likes to talk about
these big numbers oh my gosh it makes so
much more
but a lot of it is stock compensation
and if the company didn't go up
why aren't any airline ceos on there i'd
be willing to bet there's one or two
airline ceos that have a higher
cash based salary with medical benefits
a bunch of perks
than some of these guys listed but they
didn't have the the stock based
compensation that went with it that
drove it
up and so you know i think it's a bit of
a vanity stat
but it is to the victor in terms of
building
enterprise value and that's what um
that's what these guys are paid to do
tom today i think it's fair to say
one of the biggest criticisms that
ceos get like yesterday guy sends me a
message saying it's unfair that
zuckerberg's is making this much more
times than his employees are
and these ceos are making a hundred
times more than their employees are et
cetera et cetera right
so we're bashing these guys that are
making money so here's a question
if i'm a kid okay we're in college
if we're in college and we're partying
together
and we're going out there we're having a
drink or whatever we're doing okay we're
going
obviously something you never did
because i know you were very
conservative but so
so yeah exactly a different uh type of
partying
which i i'm willing to bet tom knows
more about wheat than anybody in this
room combined i am willing to bet tom
knows more about weed than anybody he
can do clinic you can do case study on
it
but let me go back to my question here
when we're in college
when we're in high school when you're
hanging out with your buddies
what do you what do you dream about what
do you sit there and say you say one day
i want to be what hey johnny what do you
want to be when you grow up what do you
want to do what do we talk about
be rich yeah you want to be what i want
to be like mike i want to be like mike
was one of them right i'm going to be
like mike okay who do you want to be
who who did you want to be when you were
in high school we're in 11th grade with
you kyle what was your dream what would
you say
what was your sam what was yours you
know maybe sam from colombia said i want
to be like pablo when i grew up i don't
know what's what's your dream paul you
said you wanted to be who
is it arnold you wanted to be arnold the
greatest bodybuilder of all time
sam what was yours you wanted to be what
top ceo of a company
top c over company okay was that really
yours is that really yours what's yours
i wanted to be the next denzel
washington you wanted to be next dance
at washington what was your support in
high school
i was going to take that seriously down
yeah seriously what's up costas
honestly yes freaking awesome what was
yours when i was in
when i was in high school in high school
were in high school where lunch were
having grilled cheese
you know whatever pizza we're having
whatever good food they give to high
school kids
do you who who's tom want to be i had
read about the birth of microsoft and i
wanted somehow to be part of a tech
company
okay freaking do you realize like we all
dreamt about one day
being somebody important right right and
now i
am so confused when the media says these
guys are getting overpaid there's an
element of me as a kid that wants to
think about somebody getting overpaid
there's there's an element of a kid
dreaming about saying i want to see one
guy score more points than everybody
else
like can you imagine this question would
you like to see somebody beat the world
chamberlain record of a hundred hundred
points
would you like to see i would would you
want us would you want to see would you
want to see somebody beat the 74
home run record with barry bonds without
steroids a 220 pound skinny guy doing 75
home runs would you like to see
that yes would you like to see joe
dimaggio's 56 game hit streak being
broken
would you like to see somebody you know
win five world series in a row maybe
it's never
been done before would you like to see
somebody get seven rings and someone
went four pete not three people
we want to see these records being taken
place i don't understand the logic
behind
saying this is too much money they're
making
because it's not good for society to
have somebody make this much more money
well why don't you since you feel you
can do better
why don't you go create a website that
has 3 billion users
if you do that we'll pay you handsomely
why don't you
go become so good at what you do where
you become the ceo of the number one
search engine in the world
you go do it if you can do that props to
you maybe you deserve 400 million
compensation why are we so much
about criticizing people who win at the
highest level in america i'm so confused
why maybe one of the reasons is some of
these people are unlikable and they're
tech companies and they're hard to root
for
so that could be one small reason but
the media just in general
that that's their mentality they always
want to root against the big guy
they want safe they want you know these
aren't big thinkers we're talking about
in media that are writing these stories
so
you know it's always that us versus them
mentality
i i okay the real me
you know i will tell you something and i
wasn't being safe i was being honest
what i said
if you take a look at what some of these
ceos make just the cash compensation
there's a there's a lot of alignment
across industries
but the airlines didn't go up and so the
stock didn't go up and so they didn't
make all the extra money so they're not
on the
hit list of overpaid overpaid leader
punks that everybody wants to call them
out to be but i got to say this
i am glad that mark zuckerberg made what
he made
because it meant the value of the
company was increased number one and
number two
he made a hell of a lot of jobs you may
not like what all those jobs are doing
in terms of censoring and things like
that
but he made a bunch of jobs i am glad
that google is made that that guy you
know sundar
made the money because it means that
google is still expanding and there's
jobs that are being created
i see that side of it from an
entrepreneurial lens and i tell people
really well let me tell you a world
without billionaires means we
all eat ramen noodles do you really want
that do you want that no nobody wants
that
and so that's that's how i feel about
that it's like it's easy to be envious
of the other guy
when some people are a little too
critical or a little too lazy or a
little too envious or a little too
jealous
it's easy to be critical but then you
got to step back and look at it
and you know for every google you talk
about oh
you remember the auto industry and it
decimated flint michigan because it got
out competed against and then it went
down
and now look at flint yeah but you know
what people had jobs in flint and front
was built and
the world changed and you know
the rust belt and u.s steel went and
these are cycles and they hurt and
they're bad
and people talk about them like that but
you know you're just
criticizing the people at the at the
beginning the jobs are correct you know
who makes this mistake the most and they
don't even know how how costly the
mistake is
you know who makes this mistake the most
and it's so costly
parents parents
parents make the mistake imagine this
kid's dream is to one day be a sunday
a sunday imagine this kid's dream is to
one day be a ceo of
you know a facebook imagine the sketch
and the mom says these
rich people let me tell you these rich
people
and the kid says mom i kind of wanted to
do to impress you
now mom made no incentive for this kid
to do that
and long term he could have been the
winning ticket for the entire family
but the parent killed the kids
dream let the kid dream
on what he wants to do i think that's
who ends up paying the biggest price and
they don't even know
you know i interviewed you you know the
whole no more mr nice guy the book i
don't know did you ever
end up getting it or not i bought it did
you read it yeah i felt he was talking
to me
did you read it no i did i did it it
started off with a bang
there's no question i'd say the first 80
pages outstanding got a little clinical
in the middle maybe it
ran out of things to say picked up at
the end so i thought it was a very good
book so what'd you think was it a good
book
no i think it was gonna give you some
perspective you didn't think about
before no i
literally the guy with his background
with with everything he's observing did
he kind of talk to you a little bit
i mean i think anybody can look at that
book and say there might be a little bit
about me i agree so i interviewed the
guy last week okay he reached out
my booker allen who's ridiculous he
listens to everything we do and he just
kind of reaches out to people he says
hey i got the guy
let's do the interview so we do the
interview okay while we're doing the
interview i say so you know tell me
about you know how big of a role we talk
about real interesting stuff i said how
big of a role does the first time you
ever have sex to
have to do with uh us for the rest of
our lives he says
everything i said so that means we're
all screwed
your first sexual experience ruins your
life
i said okay so we went through
especially if you were alone at the time
well that's that's he said that's okay
we talked about that as well by the way
i know what you're saying about that we
talked about that as well
but you know one of the things i said so
what do you say about parenting
he says here's the thing with parenting
just
make sure you're gonna screw your kids
up
just make sure it's not too much okay
what interesting feedback
you're going to screw your kids up just
don't think
just don't do it too much because if you
do too much these kids are going to be
grown up
worried about walking on eggshells this
egg shows that extra this
you know i think when you see something
like this you know i wonder what kids
are talking about with their parents at
their house
you know if you're sitting at the dinner
table and mom says rich people are bad
dad says rich people are greedy these
people these people that kid is kind of
like
you know so maybe the best guy that
could have ran
a great company been a great ceo done a
thing better than elon musk or any of
these guys did
maybe maybe that nurturing maybe that
challenge and that pushing maybe that
wasn't there i don't know
well maybe i'm fully off if you have the
drive to do that you're probably going
to overcome some of those negative
you know impulses you're getting from
their parents or whatnot but you know
you mentioned you know your interview
with the guy that wrote mr nice guy
talking about your first sexual
experience
i was listening to a different podcast
victory the podcast which is about
entourage all the guys from ontra so
if you like entourage it's a great
podcast with doug ellen and they had
james kahn on the show because scott
khan
used to be on entourage right the actor
yes so james khan was on there talking
about and
man have times changed but when scott
khan turned 16
james khan got him a sweet at the four
seasons and brought in a couple of heidi
fleisch's girls
hey you're 16 now so can you imagine his
first sexual experience is with a couple
of heidi fleisch's girls
you know what charlie sheens was charlie
sheen used his dad's credit card to get
a couple prostitutes
that's what charlie she did and it's
that's like what's this mindset i got a
couple problems you got
can you imagine like everybody has a
different story with the first
experience but
he said it has such a big impact of who
you become
so again have to battle this by the way
i can't wait for people to see that
interview because
it was very very different the things we
talk about is very different on what
shapes
boys to become men and some men still
have their own boy tendencies
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye